ignore my hair I just went for a run all
right here's the deal I will start and
only fans if you meet my conditions if
you've been watching my channel for a
while this may not be much of a surprise
you'll probably just roll your eyes and
say to yourself oh there goes Mark again
getting naked when nobody asked but if
you're relatively new to my channel this
might be slightly confusing or
concerning arrest assured I know what
I'm doing in the past I made a lovely
little calendar called Markiplier's
tasteful nudes calendar where I did
exactly as the title describes and I
sold it for charity it was so successful
that we sold over 38 000 of these
calendars of which I spent eight days of
my life hand signing each one my only
fans will be much the same except I
won't be signing it but all of the
proceeds will be donated to charity
however I will only make it only fans if
you meet the following conditions number
one you listen to distractible in the
description you'll find links to the
podcast that Bob Wade and I made
together but you don't just need to
listen to distractible that would be too
easy you need to listen so hard with
enough new listeners that you launch
distractible to number one on both the
Apple podcast charts and Spotify thereby
dethroning Joe Rogan Believe It or Not
we've actually done this uh we were
number one on Spotify before and we're
for a brief day we were past Joe Rogan
but we've never been number one on Apple
podcasts and both of those conditions
need to be met some simultaneously or I
will not make an only fans condition
number two you listen to go my favorite
sports team Tyler and I also made a
podcast where Tyler finally gets to flex
his master's degree in sports but also I
don't know anything about sports I don't
watch sports I don't really follow
Sports I don't really care much about
sports but that's the point of the
podcast it's a bridge connecting the
people that love sports and the people
that absolutely don't love sports or
everyone in between where they can sit
down and in common understanding try to
identify the weird Wild World of Sports
at least that's my perspective I am a
little peeved that the only episode that
I did not host where Wade stepped in
because I was sick just so happens to be
the most popular episode of that podcast
that that doesn't seem very fair
considering I have recorded dozens of
these and I have learned so much about
sports I could tell you what I learned
but don't ask me what I learned because
I definitely know what I learned you
don't need to know what I know what I
learned
but that's another topic for another day
go my favorite sports team has to become
the number one sports podcast in America
and the world there is a subcategory for
podcasts for sports it must for all the
world to see to sit at the top of those
charts and for all the other sports
podcasts to look upon and week at my
knowledge of sports that I definitely
have these are my conditions and the
links to meet these conditions are
available in the description below or
you can simply search for distractible
NGM FST on their respective podcast
sites if you don't meet these conditions
then I will not make an only fans my
tasteful nudes will not be released to
the world some of you may not wish for
this to happen in the first place and
want to stop the other people that are
sprinting headlong into tasteful nudes
too that's up to you I'm fine either way
and I will relish the competition that
you stir up but if you do want this to
happen and you do want me to make an old
fans and you do want tasteful nudes too
to exist in the world then all you need
to do is be
and I will follow through and all of the
proceeds through only fans will be
donated to charity good luck and thank
you for enabling me